what's your gym routine looked like in
2020 because
there was a period that i brought up
with dave rubin when he came on the show
um maybe sort of the last 18 months up
until the start of this year
where you went from normal douglas
murray
to jacked douglas murray i want to know
i want to know what you've been doing um
[Music]
not the subject i talk about very much
the simple reason is i've stopped
wearing suits partly because i thought
if it was going to be the end of the
world i didn't have to put on a tie
and
um and um but i i've worked out all
well for quite a long time 15 years 20
years or so
uh for me it's it's um it's like the
most important point in the day when i
turn my mind off uh
i think it's very very good for people
for that people like me who basically
work all the time
it would not work all the time think all
the time you know when i'm not writing
i'm reading and
and you know and that's great but i
actually do need a time to turn off
and so for me the gym has always been
that
um and uh well i mean
i don't know if i can tell you my exact
routine that means a chest is it a
push-pull leg split what are you in five
days a week
the people i know yeah normally four or
five days a week uh
three at the absolute worst lockdown was
tricky as it was for a lot of people
because however many of those banned
things you get they never quite
approximate
the weight um and um and i'm also
very anti-running in public
okay sorry i'm very very
it's not just i don't like to do it
myself i don't like seeing people coming
towards me on the pavement jibbering and
sweating and
dribbling so
so for me exercise has to be in the gym
it has to be confined to that place i
think whatever you did
over the the 18 month period there was i
can't remember where the photo was that
went sort of
semi semi sort of viral online i was
weirdly i know exactly what you're
talking about because it was something
behind it's a lot there's a lot of
tricep in it and
it was it was a beard it was when i um
discovered what a thirst pick was which
was not something i'd ever
encountered before people said to me
you've posted a first pick and i said
what's that
and uh yes i know exactly what it was i
was in mexico and i happened to be
in the study that trotsky was
assassinated in
which is not the obvious place if you
lost the first trap
picture you were deliberately posting a
first pick you probably wouldn't choose
an assassination
site um anyhow
it was very kind of and flattering of
people
and um i'm deeply grateful and obviously
the next book
will be a davina mccall like workout
with douglas
i want a home dvd booty bums and toms
with douglas murray and comment below
comment below if you'd buy it and maybe
we'll get that
you